and Tracy's planning a huge surprise for
me at the end really what is it I don't
know Liz it's a surprise do you know
what a surprise is
now you do that's the hilarious and
talented Sherry Shepard on the TV show
30 Rock the comedian and actress also an
Emmy winner for her role as host on The
View and she just launched her own talk
show called
Sherry Sherry Shepard shares her comedic
takes on today's pop culture news and
interview celebrities including her
childhood Crush Donny Osborne take a
look have to say
you had a poster of me I remember you
telling me talk show yeah and you used
to kiss it I used to kiss your poster
all the time Donnie yeah we recreate the
moment
I've been tested I'm covered free
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no it wasn't planned at all you know I I
told everybody when they said Donny
Osmond is coming on I said oh I had a
poster in my room and I used to kiss it
all the time his poster and and that's
what I remembered and they told him that
so it was so exciting I just think
nobody can do what you do I think people
forget that you're an actress you're a
comedian and now you're on The View and
now you have your own show and you seem
so ready for this moment to me well I
think it's been Gail it's been like over
18 years in the making I've always
dreamed about having a talk show and yes
and I I would drink literally when I was
little I would have my little toilet
paper roll with my teddy bears and my
Barbies and I would like ask them
questions they would be lined around me
but I've always I would always look at
talk shows I love them and I go what
would I do do different how would I do
this and I so it's really every day it's
like wow I'm living this dream of course
and I get to do and I think people get
to see me unleash you got to see little
Snippets of me of what I do on The View
and different things but it's like
whatever I want to do it's different
when it has your name on it yeah you've
got the talent for it you got the
experience for it but one thing you do
before every show is pray I pray yes
before every show before every show I
pray with John Murray uh my executive
producer he comes and he holds my hand
and then I'll have my Glam team and we
pray we pray for the people who are
watching the show and the people that
are in the audience that they feel the
joy that I'm trying to bring them and
that they feel you know the love in the
hour and yeah and we also pray that they
get my jokes that they laugh how did
being a stand-up prepare you for this so
I would I always think that stand-up
comedy is the hardest thing in the show
business you know because you got to get
on stage I get on stage for not when I
headline 90 minutes and I have to make
you laugh that's what you pay for so I'm
used to doing that so our set is so
small it's not a big Sound Stage it
feels like a comedy club so I'm just
telling stories if I got to go rant
about accepting dog poo in New York and
I or you know the parking signs I can't
understand how to park in New York it's
a story and I'm used to doing that on
stage you really do talk about what you
see you know I I think I think it's
great that you pray before the show
Oprah used to go down in the elevator by
herself she wanted to be in there alone
she would have a brief meditation before
she went on yeah and I know that she's
cheering you on she sent you something
on your first day let's show it and I'm
curious about the advice she gave you
what did she say
S
I just feel like I want to dress like
Oprah today
and put on look at that yeah that's
that's
oh that's awesome come out so instead of
meat you brought out the flowers that
was her way yeah my mind what was her
advice to you Oprah oh it was 15 pages
it was 59 minutes exactly she said she
said doing a talk show is how low did
sacred ground
big responsibility and she said like
that said it just like that and I was
like okay well there you go bro I just
wanted to show viral videos and she
wouldn't know and she said and she said
Sherry doing her talk show is like God
giving you a kiss on the lips really yes
she did and I was like he loved me that
much oh did Barbara walsher say
something to you too back in the day
Barbara Walters changed your career she
said always be curious and she said
lower your voice
she said people you project more
confidence when your voice is deep
because when I first got on The View I
was like hi I'm sure you take a little
time to enjoy the view by the time I
left I sounded like a full-grown man you
know it's like James Earl Jones James
Earl Jones but I always tell the my
interns I always say lower your your
voice you just want us to have a good
time which isn't that what you want have
a great time watching this year you
should feel good we're going through too
much A lot of times we're desensitized I
want you to be able to let go for one
hour like Oprah said to me it's about
the energy you put out and I want you to
get that energy and feel like I can
conquer the world I can laugh well you
are putting out the good energy I'm
looking at the dress could you please
leave that behind it's our question for
John Rogers
like I'm loving it's really really
Sinclair III who is the the the just his
inspiration is amazing well I know that
you're I love it so many people watching
thank you so much thank you for coming
thank you very much can you guys come on
the show of course oh my God thank you
watch scary weekdays check your local
listings we'll be right back